sometimes we get animals that come in
and it's almost like they know something
is wrong with the other yeah that
companionship is definitely a big thing
let's say we know we have two hamsters
or guinea pigs you take one away and the
other just become very vocal like look I
want my friend back and I want my friend
back now oh so now you w't even talking
now yeah you see your mama now you're
acting up you know you have some animals
that are fine by themselves but some
species like and pig just like to have
I'm not fine by myself I'm not either I
don't like to be alone I'm glad I got
you man no doubt cuz when you leave you
should hear me man I'm vocal man it's
almost like I have
[Music]
anxiety at the beginning of a new day Dr
Hodes gets a chirp of fresh air oh look
what we got got some chickies some
chickies so how's every everybody doing
in here I came and brought my chicks in
to get a checkup ever since I was little
we've always gotten chicks and raised
them you can take him out in the front
yard and they'll follow you around and
you can just hold them in your hand and
they'll snuggle up in your
hand PE can I
see ah we got a little poopy there I am
going to check the stew samples one
thing we worried about is coxidia and
other parasites coxidia is a protoo that
lives in the intestinal tract of these
birds and and they cause diarrhea anemia
is very very contagious and
unfortunately they kill these birds
really really fast what's this's name
Kevin Kevin hello Kevin how are you
Kevin is kind of big he'll be the one
I'll have them check the stew but let's
see if you're Kevin or kette so we're
going to see if you know how to sex well
may figure out the sex is I'm looking at
the different feathers and the patterns
so let me show you so we got long mm
short long and I'm looking in between
short long short this is a little girl
ah if the feathers are alternating in
length then the chick is a female hello
kette hey Jordan I need you to take
kette this used to be Kevin okay kette
kette now all right so I want you to
check and I want you to set up a stew
something for okay hi the plot thickens
and what's this's name Michael so what
we're going to do is play a game of is
this name correct since they're all even
we have Michael by we have a winner good
job and what's this one's name Bert
Reynolds I'm a very big fan of Bert and
look how even that is see how even mhm
this is BT she got you right and look at
your bottom ah nice and clean so do you
know who chicka chicka chick chick this
is that is Leroy Leroy oh we might have
to name this one ler really wrecked and
what's this one's name Edna Edna let's
see long short long short we have Ed
hello you'll know what this one is come
on we got it look it's a girl look at
that what's this name going to be nugget
hello Chicken N how are you and since
they're all even we have a boy all right
good job and what's our name Tony
Montana Tony Montana say hello to my
little friend
these guys look really good nice and
healthy I'm just going to go look at
that stew sample and I'll be right back
okay I am looking for parasites
specifically coxidia or what we call ois
ois are baby coxidia eggs which is very
common in these guys I don't see
anything no coxidia which is great so
couple easy cheap things you can do have
you ever heard of die to this earth m i
want you to get a little de just
sprinkle around and what they'll do
they'll keep all the mites and keep all
the worms away and also their water
right apple cider vinegar 1 tbspoon per
gallon and that will also help keep the
bacteria Bay in the intestin track and I
think you got this all down
packed so now you know how to sex a
chick Edna is a girl nugget is a girl so
they get to stay Bert Reynolds and Tony
Montana are boys so they get to stay
like that we'll just have to find new
names for the other
ones
the docks roll out to the country to see
their next patient as the bad weather
rolls
in boy we're in the middle of a tropical
storm and it would be named Sally and
what be named Sally after my mom oh man
so don't talk too bad about I talk too
much bad about S I mean I've already
talked to her about it exactly I told
her to get out of here please but it
makes it more difficult out here
rain and wind rain wind and cold yeah we
could have picked a better day but you
know what cows always pick days like
this cows always pick days like this
what you say CR fix all the SC CR fix on
SC what's up bro how you doing man what
you got going mama cow she had a baby
and herter is swollen okay and she can't
give uh milk to the cow okay where's the
cow the cow is on the right okay and
where's the calf at in the barn okay
great all right we'll get that let's see
if we can get this fixed up the mama had
her baby and her other swollen and it's
hard and when we tried to see if the
milk was good for the baby it smells and
it tastes
bad all right we're going to try to get
a halter on her and then walk her over
we going to get a good place to tire up
oh no she got when maybe out bir hanging
out back here yeah see check again there
was a placenta and stuff hanging out the
cou so I'm thinking please please Lord
don't let there be another calf in here
which would be a
whole other problem you
ready all right let's bump I'm back here
girl Dr Hodes bumps the cow's backside
to alert her of his
presence it's probably warmer in here
than he is out
there who no what are you pulling out
I'm seeing out the bir but I'm reaching
in I'm hoping it's not remnant of
another calf if another calf is still
inside the docks will have to find a way
to remove it I have to try to
distinguish I'm hoping we a got another
calf in there it's going to be a long
night boss oh hold no hold no hold no
hold no yeah watch them back legs I feel
after bir but I don't feel no
care well that's
good everybody on her masam M they got
after birth y she would normally try to
push it out her s but a lot of times
they get milk fever or clamps you I mean
you need calcium to make milk you need
calcium to push you need calcium to make
your muscles go she got a big bag so
sometimes just the uterus just is not
getting stimulated by the hormones and
it doesn't contract to push everything
out come on help me out girl I feel
it Dr Hodes removes the remaining
afterbirth to help Mom out we will be
doing this in the middle of a tropical
storm yeah we wouldn't have it any other
way
I I'll have another
way all right I think that's it boss all
right we can jump down here on this
teeth you can see these tis are inflamed
so we're going to get in here and get
everything thing cleaned up we're going
to infuse some medication in there for
anti-inflammatory and and some
antibiotics all right how you do that
let's go see how this calf
know Dr Hodges quickly moves to the
newborn calf hey I know you been sitting
out here how you doing you confused hey
let's make him a little bot you know I
go over to check on this calf and
immediately my heart sinks because I
know this calf is in trouble you got to
figure out how to do this come on come
on I see a calf that's confused barely
standing hasn't been able to nurse so I
got to figure out how to get some
nutrients in this calf as fast as I can
this thing is still full of milk and if
it stays in there you see it's getting a
little soft here so it's getting
absessed baby's not going to be the
nurse here it was getting ready to
rupture on his
so we going to make a little incision
with a blade there and let it drain some
come on we got to keep doing keep
stimulating rubing that b keep
stimulating
yeah all right you ready buddy late yep
that's all right baby see it's kind of
draining there there you go is that what
I'm smelling do oh yeah you smelling
some milk that you don't want to drink
kind of like bar milk you know it's been
in there and it can't get out we got to
get this baby warmed up let's get him in
the car and let's turn the heat on okay
okay let's go come on let's get let's
get him in the car and get some heat how
the C doing what's going on hard trying
to get him warm boss he cold it doesn't
matter what is a puppy a calf a kitten
if their body temperature drops down
below 1 2 maybe 3° they just W nurse get
them warmed up I'm going go check on Dr
fer okay I got to figure out a way to
get this calf warm and get some
nutrients in his body this cow got to be
feeling a whole lot better prognosis is
pretty good it just going to take time
these are your medication here okay okay
one per day for both teeth but baby
going to have to be bottle fed we going
to get him back to the clinic give him
some round the treatment man this kind
of a life and death situation so we need
to get up out of here okay yes sir all
right when you take the baby cal name
them vard that's a name of Champions I
feel confident that Mama Will Survive
and baby cal will be treated well let's
get out of here get you some warrant
baby I got to get this calf back to the
clinic hey
I mean it's cold it's wet it's
disoriented cuz it hadn't seen his mom
so my first thing is to get nutrients we
got to try to teach this calf how to eat
just like a kid newborn calves require
colostrum the first nutrient-dense milk
produced by Mom right after giving birth
I got to get some colossum and milk in
this calf fast cuz the gut only accepts
colossum for 24 hours after that 24
hours the claustrum is no good we got
some claustrum we're going to get that
and over the next 24-hour period so it's
going to be a long
night where's mom the other Mama of the
puppies she they got it
back with Adobe yep so I got this do
picture penny that came in it's been at
home and the owner did get out four
puppies but she noticed that the animal
is in a little bit of distress so she
called and I told her just come on up
here so the last puppy was in distress
for prob cuz it was first in the back
the car this is the one that she had in
the car so I'm just tying off the
umbilicus now usually mom would you know
kind of chew on it and gnaw on it until
it goes but she wasn't doing very well
with
them no big girl so let's see one two 3
four moms can have what we call uterine
inertia where they have pups they get
tired the uterus kind of wears down and
they can be a period between having a
pup and another one even up to a day
it's Puppet Time Puppet Time of the Year
yeah time of the year man babies can get
caught in the burken now and it's almost
like a train a locomotive cuz when one
stop all of the puppies become
distressed and this is a very big cause
concern because it can kill the puppies
and it can also kill the mom she
bleeding come here about so get mum
excuse
me is another one coming out just it's
just moonium so okay let's get that
clean when moonium a puppy's first stool
is released into the amniotic fluid it's
a sign of severe distress we've been
waiting around for pending to have the
rest of these puppies she's not really
having any contractions so we decided to
give her a little bit of oxytocin to
help these puppies alone let's go ahead
and put her in this kennel and let's put
a a dark towel over the kennel so what
oxytocin does is it goes in and the
simulates the muscles inside the Urus to
contract so hopefully she can push these
puppies
out you need to have these
puppies we going to give you something
to help you out a little bit we really
don't want to do a C-section so I'm
hoping we can get all these puppies out
of here
naturally we got oh we had one over here
oh grab it grab it grab it grab it grab
it after a shot of oxytocin she's
delivering another pup so she goes ahead
and she delivers a pup but we notice
she's not cleaning the after bir so this
puff is still stuck in the amnionic sa
come
on there we go come on and if we don't
quickly get the passes ways and the
mouth and nasal cap it open this pupple
will suffocate and die really
fast there we
go come on good
job there you go are
yours some First Time Moms can um not be
very mature they're not sure what to do
they won't remove the sack from Mom or
they won't clean the pups up and that
can be the difference between life and
death so we have to
intervene oh we got one we got one we
got one we got one we got one you got it
you're it's okay give me towel towel
towel yeah our do just had another puppy
I know it we knew there were four we
need two more boys you hear me so we got
two more at least cuz we saw we knew we
saw four okay so that's two they still
can't count they still can't count it's
what they old
age oh here we
go get her D get her I
got it's okay Mommy it's okay mommy
going to have a time with you go ahead
and get ready for this next one it oxy
to it work for sure stimulate milk look
let down now oh yeah it's coming down
too buddy coming in good hopefully with
the the oxytocin we'll get number eight
out of here real soon we need to get the
baby on it too so while Penny's milk has
come in her motherly instincts haven't
so what we going to do we're going to
lay Mama down and let you be with Mom
but we're going to bring pups in too
okay we want to try to put them on there
and see if we can let them nurse a
little bit it's very important that we
get the other pups on Penny so that they
can nurse because there been a time
interval between the first pup and the
last one that we're still waiting on and
we want to make sure they get their
first milk which is called colostrum
mommy going to rub you you got a mama
okay right there he knew exactly what to
do they all trying to get to the top
yeah they all want the top one come on
girl you see him come on girl all right
GL up Dr Ferguson is coming
[Music]
up put the
towel how they doing as far as nursing
how they been are everybody been nursing
and had a chance on the teeth
where you going trying to take off here
thank you so much not of
problem oh goodness it's all about
patience y everybody's waiting on you
number eight in this case we had a good
outcome so everything worked out um she
started nursing but she did well and the
pups did
well so we here to see the big fella who
the big fella d DWI Howard the Dwight
Howard yeah man he just won a
championship with the Los Angeles Lakers
last year all right so it's really cool
this is a huge farm D here yeah I think
like a couple hundred acres or so yeah
so it should be a lot of fun
yes what up what's up how's it going y
made it out here made it yeah we are at
our farm here in Lexington Georgia it's
734 Acres we got some great cattle we
got some chickens got a nice Lake it's a
lot to take care of my latest calf in
the herd need to be dewormed and
vaccinated and we have a lake we have
check the ammonia levels in the water to
make sure that uh the water is perfect
so we can have a great spring next year
with the fish and I'm having some
tremendous problems with my chickens
appreciate you guys coming today tell me
what we got going my needs to be
dewormed and a kind of water quality
problems and a couple problems with my
chickens all right we'll get your calf
and chicken sorted up I'm a fish guy I
got a fish degree besides being a vest
I'm going to teach you some country boy
tricks out going to get some big fish
out of there all right like a yeah we
going to see
I'm I was going to teach you how to get
that pawn right I guarantee well we'll
head to the cow past all right let's go
first the docks head over to the cow
pasture to vaccinate and deworm the
Howard's newest
calf right on this
side we need to separate mom from the
cuz we actually vaccinating the cab I
don't really want to get gored by a horn
you're not not a long horn not a short
horn not a show horn not any horn not
any horn so we got to make sure that we
have a good plan cuz we want to make
sure everybody's safe T you got your
rope you got our stuff I'm the decoy VJ
is the Gat man if I say open that gate
and I'm running you better open that
gate all right I got you yes Terence and
me going to see if we can flush mom to
the bottom or in here that's our game
plan Dwight going to be out Lookout he
going to be able to see over top I got
you you know he going to do what he do
best andless the bull come over here
Dwight you go fast I'm out of here look
look look don't you move unless we give
you word okay all
right this calf never been touched by
humans so this calf is going to be
running trying to figure out how can I
get from these guys right and we have to
really be concerned with safy yeah
because you got cows that are th000 lb
they're full speed they can trample you
trample would you rather be trampled or
would you rather be gored neither yeah
just walk him that way all the way
around the edge of it closed down there
right yeah it's a fence let's see if we
can push him that way take them all the
way back stay right there hard stay on
point I'm in the middle all right come
on Mama come on Mama matter of fact go
ahead and open that gate and swing it
back we might have to get all three of
them Paul push push F over the
gate let him through i j Ferguson
oh he went
tumbling I'm up all
right I'm good y might had to go to plan
B that Dr hard one of us going to get TI
I hope it not us man enough is enough
we're going to Corral this cab One Way
Or Another We're going to do whatever we
need to do I am tired I am tired of
chasing this cab hey man let's make it
happen right now all right close in
tight
together I'm between you and keep out
that corner come on C close tighter all
right keep him that way Paul we can use
the corners of our
friends let's go good job got my D wor
all right down the B all right let's go
all right we done we are we got him good
job go see your mom oh you not ready
done to work got him done we got on the
ground hey we can't risk no more chance
of getting nowhere else champ you can
let the confet down we did
it we did it hey you can just let the
confet come
I did my part yes sir you did thank you
bro and then when you fell I was going
to run over there yeah I po up kind of
quick I was like all right they told me
to stay over here and watch don't be
heroic I saw it in slow motion from this
from this angle like yes I saw it Mo but
you did a good job you got up quick you
got right back to the for age I did
pretty good man go check out this Lake
check out Lake all
right all right I had jaku sto down here
with me we're basically going to look at
this Lake because he say got a lot of
mediumsized fish but not a lot lot of
large fish when I examine this water I'm
hoping I see really good quality being
balanced is very very important the
ecosystem is Pond it kind of feeds off
each other you need F planting for the
little fish to eat and so that the big
fish can eat the little fish and then
they all grow so with the help of a
simple pwan you can tell a lot about
what's going on with the ecosystem of a
pond look a simple pan right you want to
put it down this going to be a little
shallow big fell I might need your arms
do come here I want you to get this out
a little bit further from me when I do
the pod test if you can see it at a
really deep depth then it tells me that
the figh plank is out of order if it's
really clear you don't have any F
planing now stick it right there right
here keep going down at 18 in you
shouldn't be able to see that you should
have some kind of zlan or phytoplank
basically algae it should be green Al y
so you need the algae to feed the zlan
to feed the insects to feed the small
fish so the big fish can eat and it's
real simple just want you to put some
phosphorus fertilizer in here I'll tell
you exactly what to get that's
right just like running to play big guy
while we here Paul's taking water
samples so we can figure out exactly
what's going on with this water we
tested the water okay all right we're
going to start with uh the nitrate you
know okay all right I'm hoping we don't
see too many nitrates which in turn will
actually kill the F plant and I have
enough growth so we want to have just
the right amount of nitrogen which will
definitely lead to a Lar larger F
population zero parts per million okay
so this needs to be darker just a little
bit darker I like it be about about
right here between the purple and lavend
it's a little low it's a little low
that's why we're going to add some
fertilizer okay so you want some purple
and
[Applause]
gold what you want of that Championship
quality
quity so to get this war the
championship quality D and his father
just simply have to add a little bit of
liquid fertilizer and that's an easy fix
so now we're moving into the fourth
quarter with the fou you going to ruffle
some feathers with
that so what's up with the chicken no
eggs no eggs the chickens man they're
not laying a lot of eggs my hope is that
we're not dealing with a parasitic
problem where did it come from I
inherited from a chicken house okay a
lot of time that's why they getting rid
of them because they aren't lay so we
going to check this one out we going to
go here my with my two trusty chicken
catchers and I'm going to take a little
look here you ain't taking Dwight there
to catch chicken it's a little too
low let's look in there all right okay
we going to get a sample of this stew I
want to make sure no um cityia we
call in there and that could be a reason
aren't laying I'm going to check for
coxidia which is a parasite it'll not
only be an issue for this chicken but as
well as the other
birds all right looking good so far I
don't see anything okay I think the
issue is is more age related once they
get older like that they not going to
lay anymore just whole age in a
production you know we want egg we
probably have to start out with some
ones that are a little bit younger and
then kind of grow them into it all right
all right man we got a lot done today
wrestling cows checking water checking
chickens making sure they weren sick
they just old just old yeah but we got
it all taken care of I see three
championships see it claim it your
future looking bright then huh DWI has
been quite enthusiastic and a team
player throughout this whole thing hey
man we may have another employee
T official Critter Fixer hey look at
that yes today was an amazing day I
learned a little bit about you know the
what goes on inside the Critter Fixer
world and I became a Critter Fixer
Critter fixing on the
scene if you need any Critter fixing
call the
hows stand up a little bit
hey what all right I know Dr hajes
continues to treat and mother Vernard
the newborn cat rather get up and eat
but got to get up and eat it's not quite
walking yet so let's take him back you
got to thrive boss M of fact let's go
outside I'm really really concerned
about
Bernard this calf needs nourishment and
mom usually does a lot of the work like
teaching them to walk and move around so
I'm just going to have to take them out
outside and see if I can teach him to
walk and get him going can't do it by
myself got get your bearings on you now
nope can't keep sitting down on me come
on now he ain't sitting in no cage we
ain't going for No Nonsense you got come
on I healthy Cal would be running around
this field and getting up and able to
get up on his own and just romping and
playing and just figuring out life but
not vard at least not right now I need
to see if I can get some more colum down
past that window you got to get this
colostrum come on yeah he stop he's
trying to spit it out hey man I'm really
concerned CU we got to get this calf
going or he's not going to live hey man
you got to hang in here come on now just
not eating still won't get up by himself
hey come on man this Cal is only eating
about a third of a pain I need him to
eat at least a pint or two he's not
going to
leave
inside the clinic Max the puppy is in
need of Emergency Care let's get an IV
cathol start man his dog is scared he
bit me this dog he ate his owner's
medicine he ate it within 15 minutes
let's go ahead and get some apomorphine
Max the pupp swallowed his owner's
medicine a human dose of cane medicine
which can be really really dangerous
when a dog swallows pills you in a
deadly race with his digestive system
we're going to go ahead and try to make
him vit since he only did it a short
while ago yes especially when they eat
some kind of toxicosis you want to try
to counteract it get out the stomach
getting fluid started should be going
we're going to get some apomorphine to
see if we can remove all the stomach
contents appom morphine has many uses
but in vetenary medicine we often time
use it to make an animal throw up and in
this case that may be the difference
between life and death you you ready you
ready all right P I know you scared give
this guy plenty of room a lot of times
these uh pain medicine is nephrotoxic
and it destroys the kidneys and liver so
hopeful we didn't digest it much here we
go here we
go going to throw up all his
insides there we go there go some of
it
yeah lot of chicken huh you see the peel
I know you're not feeling
good I know I know but you had some good
chicken huh his a it's actually yellow
so I think I got a lot of it up good
good good I'm going to go and start this
blood work yeah that's part of it he
definitely ate it best
part so that was a pretty close call we
were able to get it before you know
before the stomach emptied it out and it
went into the intestine and started to
absorb so I didn't I didn't think when I
went to vet school I'd be digging
through uh the contents of a dog's
stomach but I guess you do what you have
to
do
all right Mr Co yes sir some pieces some
remnants as it was being digested just
can't thank you enough I did get bits of
the pill still I'm worried about the
pill actually going through the system
and causing some liver or kidney
problems come on back we'll see him he's
doing okay I don't know what it' be like
without him I got him on IV fluids he
seems to be pretty stable now hopefully
24 hours we'll know for sure he to dated
uh yeah he he's kind of just out a
little bit cuz he just had to give up
all his stomach content so he's doing
okay he going to be all right I think we
got a good shot yes sir that's Beauty I
owe you that you know he's important to
our family and you're very important to
me thank you you as one of my first
clients almost 20 years ago I mean it
probably would be no CR fixes what
people like the Mr Cooks of the world we
appreciate you yes sir I thank you so
much so I'm going to put him up in a
minute I'm going to let you say goodbye
and we'll call you in the morning
hopefully once we get this fluid fluster
on but okay I'll give you a second all
right buddy you take care I know you
scared but it's hard right we're glad
that we're able to bring Max to Dr
hodges's office because uh he's as fine
a vet as you'll ever find so even though
we're worried we know he's going to get
the best care love
you while Dr hajes attends to more
patients his son VJ tries to feed baby
calf Vernard III yeah that should be
good mil
ready come here come here open your
mouth drink it drink it thank
[Applause]
you no need more than
that going to make sure you know how to
drink when you go back
home you know if you feed it more than
two times it think you mama so you going
to stay with that c forever they been
following me I know you think you mama
look this
way yeah y'all kind of resemble oh name
right what you trying to say though it
might be
Daddy enjoy the baby while you here man
yep
[Music]
how many cow people in here okay the
owner call and say you know I got a cal
that has a lump somewhere I have to
figure out what it is we're at Fort
valer State University this is not a
regular field call it's also a teaching
lab as well who going to walk me through
this process of what we need to do
Nicole come on daughter Nicole is also
in this class so I'm going to make her
come and assist me as well if we open it
up and it looks like milky or cottage
cheese then probably what we dealing
with an absess okay good all right what
should we do dra we need to drain it
right this is my first year at Fort
Valley State I'm really excited that my
dad is able to come today just learn new
things that I didn't already know even
though he is my father so now y'all
ready to hold C look excited we out of
here let's
[Music]
go I got a lot of Cs running around here
to teach the students practically what
happens they in school school they're
learning what in theory what happen now
I always say you have to be baptized
with fire so you where's the calf all
right Cal girl which one is it right
here call us over to check out one of
their Cavs they're going to go out
they're going to turn around the calf up
for us has a lump on his jaw we're here
to see what it is and and try to get
this thing taken care of got him Fe yep
all right come on here we got him on
both sides of our face okay come on we
going to go behind the truck here come
on all right I think this area right
here probably good as any all right
hold all right who you talking to all
right guys we probably got the layer
down I'll get the back and hold down you
want to get the front we going we're
going to put her down on the right side
right side
down we have to physically restrain the
calf on the ground and we're doing it so
one the calf doesn't hurt himself two we
don't get hurt or injured in the
process what I'm getting ready to do is
do a little KNE lasper and let's see if
we have anything now it seem like a
hasir regress on a little bit smaller
there any of you guys see this
beforehand yes was it larger than this
yeah yeah we're going to open it up
though and flush this pocket
out would you say that abset usually
like resolve their they always need
medical attention sometime if they open
up themselves and drain then that's good
but when they don't drain is when it get
bad cuz we don't want the animal to
become septic which means that the
bacteria stuff and now it's in the
bloodstream and they got a full-blown
infection everywhere we got a little bit
there the a has gotten hard I think it
already has drained a little bit but I
still want to open it up and get it
flushed out so it'll hit a little bit
faster what I'm going to do I'm put a
little local anesthetic in that area
then I'm just going to make a little
stab incision and we're going to flush
that area out and it has one on the
other side we're going to take a look at
that one too how we doing Cole tell
about the calf now not you the calf is
doing good good all right this is the
first time Nicole has been in a field
surgery that she's held a cow down you
know my heart is boom boom my baby girl
is out here with
Dad
Bine which is a kind of a ey dine scrub
looks pretty clean now all right what's
his name we have to name the cast today
joh number
18 check the other side
R man y'all look like an
expert I take my syringe and I do
another fine needle as print all right
look at this one that's a little bit
different the other side is it yeah and
voila white substance comes in the
needle with tells me this definitely is
an active
absess all right there we go just a
little blackhead ain't
it these kids want to be veterinarian
but when they saw that white PFF come
out they were like ooh but I know it's
probably for some of them the first
surgery they've ever seen that hits all
of us like that the first time trying to
flush all this old purulent cotage
cheese looking stuff out of there it'll
be good healthy tissue and then this
thing will heal up hey you glad we came
today his eyes are up you winking at
Sierra that's what it is hey buddy yeah
a okay okay we can let him up you go all
right all right baby should be fine so
who going to be in charge of watching
the Cs and make sure everything good
everybody raise your hand no no one
person I enjoyed you guys today one
ain't no go g all latest you can know
everything in the book but if you've
never actually Hands-On done a certain
procedure it's not going to do you any
justice whether you have the information
or whether you don't the students seem
to be really engaged and really excited
and I do feel definitely proud just to
see how everyone looks up to him hope I
didn't bore you all too much today all
right give yourself a hand all right
good deal it's been an awesome trip I
have students out here that are watching
asking question and I'm hopeful that
they learned something I think they
did I ain't did this in 15
years tooot in between patients the docs
take time to warm up a bottle of formula
for Vernard the baby calf K doing pretty
good he's doing good I came up here this
morning and he walked around I took the
shift last night I took the 4:00 shift
okay and then I came back at 700 Sierra
came in at 12 and she said he did pretty
good but I'm making him keep him out cuz
he got to Lear move Mo up yeah the C
wasn't very Thrifty so we knew that we
had to get nutrition colostrum in this
cow so we had a rotation going during
the day feeding the cow taking the calf
outside making sure the CF was up and
being mobile cuz that's what Mom does
and doing that over and over after a few
days the CF became a lot more vibrant
thanks to me teaching how to uh walk you
do the calf walk I I taught that Cal how
to walk did you oh so that's why roll
the tapes back so that's why it's doing
like this roll the taste
back oh poor dang this floor is so slick
come on
vard good
job you looking good this morning you st
there on this stuff now huh look at you
keeping your balance I see you look at
you being
curious doing better hre yes he doing a
lot better is in a very emotional
feeling to have Bernard II watch me
interact with his calf one of the
proudest moments I've had as a dad was
him telling me he wanted to be a
veterinarian and walking my footsteps so
now he gets to watch his dad do his
craft I had to teach him how to walk and
he literally he didn't know how to walk
we just nurs him back to hell to be
honest I wasn't sure if he was going to
make it but you can't give up I mean you
going to have that seem like it's just
no way they're going to survive but you
just got to keep working with them
Andrea worked with them Paul took them
home over the weekends I had to come up
here in the middle of the night so you
going to be a veterinarian it's not a 9
to5 job so what you think cool I think
this is a great learning experience for
Bernard to see a situation that maybe
almost hopeless we are able to save this
life so hopefully that embeds in this
memory that one day as he becomes a
Vetinarian stay persistent and just
above all show these animals love no
matter what hey come on we'll have to
take care of here and keep making sure
that he thrived for
[Music]
now how Max the puppy doing man that was
a close call we ate some of our parents
pain medicine going to throw up all his
insides I was sure if he was going to
pull through but after overnight
observation mm Max is doing good and
ready to go home I'm ready to go home it
ain't sick bro so you stuck here
with me oh
man what's up Dr H my friend how you
doing buddy my friend hey girl Mr Max
what you doing buddy I see that did you
find out if he had actually oh he did I
I showed him I had I had to I got some
of out in the vomit he did I got a lot
of it out via vomiting um we did some
fluids I rechecked the blood work this
morning now liver and kidney enzymes are
really good we're doing good Hey listen
yes sir we certainly appreciate you guys
taking care of Max and the staff and Dr
Ferguson and uh just can't thank you
enough no problem he was not right night
she thought she's going to have to give
me a value no no no we good to go we
were very worried about Max so we were
doing a lot of praying and our prayers
were answered and uh we knew that Max
was in good hands Dr Hodes Dr Ferguson
everybody that works here they do great
hey buddy we certainly appreciate yes
sir see you later bye dear good to see
you Richard yes it was great to see you
guys see you
Richard you ready to bust out of
[Music]
here man I just talked to Penny's owner
Penny the doberland came in and having
some difficulty with birth she bleed
come here not so get M puppies are doing
great all right but guess what what
Penny's gotten very very protective
which is a good thing it is so she has
taken up with the pups and got real
protective of them so that mean you're
uh teaching her how to be a mom work I
have some otherly instincts I didn't
know I had good
job Penny had a hard time in the
beginning nursing the puppies we got a
problem she has made no attempt to clean
them up or nothing so we had to kind of
like coach Penny to it but this took
penny two or 3 days to get adjusted to
the puppies and she she does fine the
puppies are growing and they're getting
more active and playing and they're
healthy strong now all of them 100%
[Laughter]
good all right time to go to your mama
right the Critter fixers head back to
Aaron's family's Farm to reunite Vernard
the calf with his mother y' Can Shed
your tears for the baby's home
now today is a beautiful day and finally
get to see
Renard mama cow she's been doing really
good but in her otter the milk is
getting harder so I'm concerned let's
take a look at Mama all right see what's
going on we just want to take a look at
it and see if we got some progression
from last time make sure we heading in
the right direction here yes sir have a
right here all right look a little bit
better up
girl yeah she's still pretty in good
work yeah that's coming out there yeah
that's looking more like cheese there we
got to do that two or three times a day
just get this stuff out of there okay
okay hey she been eating okay oh she's
eating well she's drinking well she's
sleeping well oh man that's awesome at
least we know she's eating good so we
know it's not we call back tmia which
mean it gets in the bloodstream cuz they
do that then they don't want to eat yes
sir I'm glad to see her doing good but
the bad thing is you know she not going
to be able to nurse so have to be bottle
fed mom's going to be find in the long
run it won't be a it to any nursing
through this cycle here but hopefully it
we'll be it at a later time all right
Vernard you home so Aon I present to you
three vard Bernard vard
and
Bernard let's see how he does put him
down yeah let's put him down we can have
a sneak peek with your mom I am really
excited to see reard reite with his
mother we going to turn this way you may
have to hold me going back hold my head
man cuz I don't know I might shed a tear
it's kind of a sad moment man I know we
all bonded with the calf at the clinic
we need music and drum roll we need it
all man no doubt it's a special moment
it'll be tears of joy but then again you
know why can't we just keep little V3 I
know right but you lucky cuz I have V1
the original the original there you go
okay you got original vard look that's M
yeah come on come on there you go there
you go that's a good sign we checking
out the environment man and everything
is all right there you go smell and
taste familiar I think both mama and
rard are really happy to see each other
all right that's it buddy you look like
a proud pop over there you look all
nervous and holding the bottle and ready
to go home from the
nursery bye Bernard we'll come back and
visit thank
you after many days of devoted hard work
and Veterinary Care The Grateful docs
have a surprise for their staff we know
that you all been working very hard we
really appreciate you all so we wanted
to celebrate you all today so we have
food we have games all
right y'all come on all right food on
the truck let's get it let's eat the big
thing about CR fiction team effort is
everything and fortunately we have an
amazing team I need some food those look
delicious we definitely couldn't do it
without them so I'm telling you it's
tough they just make it look easy but I
know it's not come on we going to play
some corn hole could you imagine CR fix
without all I St Andre Paul and Jordan
and Richard you know and and the whole
crew you know summer running around
fussing at us about different things
look okay J I hir Jordan and you know
looking back on it that's one of the
best things that I ever did cuz she has
grown in grown in all aspects come on if
you watch me do surgery you typically
are going to hear me say talk to me Paul
was that heartbeat like Paul oh almost I
depend on Paul more than I depend on
machine
come she on my team Andre the season
Technic yeah like a whole Workhorse you
probably get mad at me she saying that
yeah it's just awesome to be able to
show them our appreciation and the love
we have for them cuz we really
appreciate it oh yeah we do good
[Music]
job